Polonia y Estados Unidos todos los
caminos apuntan a un Sabotaje contra los
gasoductos Norte extremo 1 y Norte
Stream 2 La última en sumarse a las
especulaciones Úrsula vonderleyen
presidenta de la comisión europea es
crucial ahora Investigar los incidentes
obtener total Claridad sobre los hechos
y el Por qué cualquier interrupción
deliberada de la infraestructura
energética europea activa es inaceptable
y conducirá la respuesta más fuerte
posible en los dos gasoductos se
produjeron tres fugas casi simultáneas
después de que los sismógrafos
detectaran dos explosiones el lunes el
operador de la red nord Stream age
calificó los daños sin precedentes
Polonia y Ucrania acusan a Rusia desde
Moscú responden que las afirmaciones son
estúpidas mientras crece la preocupación
entre los países bálticos estamos en una
situación grave en Europa el mar Báltico
se ha convertido en un área que hay que
esperar que en el futuro esté sujeta a
mayor extensiones las dos
infraestructuras están actualmente fuera
de servicio el norte extremo uno por una
fuga de aceite y el norte Stream 2 nunca
entra en funcionamiento después de que
Alemania suspendiera su certificación en
febrero justo antes de la invasión rusa
a Ucrania tras el daño es poco probable
que puedan operar este invierno por lo
que más que infraestructuras energéticas
se han convertido en bazas
geoestratégicas tras la fuga los precios
del gas han subido situándose un 200%
encima de hace un año mientras en
Polonia también el martes se inauguró un
gasoducto estratégico con Noruega